the US now has more reported cases of
the corona virus in any other country in
the world
think about that for just a second there
are more than 85,000 across all 50
states the death toll is about 1300
there are stay-at-home orders in at
least 23 different states New York City
remains the National epicenter of the
pandemic it has more than a quarter of
those sickened so far and this is
overwhelming the city's hospitals and
first responders our lead national
correspondent David Begg know is in New
York David good morning what are you
hearing
Tony the number of hospitalizations here
in New York jumped 40% on Thursday just
in a 24 hour period we continued to make
calls to doctors and nurses around the
city who are telling us harrowing
stories of what's happening inside but I
gotta tell you a lot of them don't feel
comfortable talking on camera because
they're worried about other being fired
and some of them are worried that their
Hospital may not tell the truth of what
is happening inside but there are some
who do feel comfortable coming forward
and that's what we're gonna start this
morning
dr. e bod Yusef of Brookdale Hospital in
Brooklyn says the emergency room is
overwhelmed and medical staff he's been
talking to across New York City are
describing similar scenes with masks on
themselves with oxygen on their nose
with oxygen on their face Elmhurst
Hospital in Queens saw 13 people die in
24 hours on Wednesday to relieve the
overcrowding some patients have been
moved to other facilities and the
hospital has added more than 50
additional staff people come in I get
intubated they die the cycle repeats
it's just a catastrophe
Mariah Sharon's 48 year old brother
Caius Kelly worked as an assistant nurse
manager at mal Sinai in Manhattan as a
child he suffered from severe asthma he
died after testing positive for the
corona virus he didn't want his parents
to know so he sent his sister a text
saying can't talk because I choked and
can't breathe
he was on a ventilator then
the last thing he did was send her and I
love you emoji sentiment from inside the
workers of that hospital was that he was
unnecessary one else they're
unnecessarily exposed and essentially it
could've been prevented yesterday in a
24 hour time period we did over 6500
calls which is a record Anthony Alma
Jarrah is a senior executive with an EMS
officers union in New York
he says emergency workers are being
stretched thin and he is afraid of the
exposure his workers are facing
consistently this is what his worst case
scenario is somebody dies a paramedic in
EMTs gonna die we have members who work
with us whoever underlying medical
conditions go home you know they go home
and grandma's home and they have
emphysema grandma gets it very much dies
regarding that nurse who died at Mount
Sinai Hospital I want to let you know
that a doctor sent me an internal memo
from the hospital which says we have
always provided and will always provide
our staff with proper protective
equipment and we have an adequate supply
we also heard from a doctor who says he
tested positive went home for a week had
no fever for three days and was asked to
come back to work so we wanted to know
what her hospitals telling their doctors
so we called 20 of them around the city
we heard back from eight and this is
what they told us if a worker has
symptoms they go home for seven days but
once that worker is asymptomatic has no
more symptoms and once their fever free
for three days they can come back to
work even if they're positive
oh boy David that is so hard to hear
it's really tough when even the people
that we need to help us now need help
it's a very very very troubling
situation thank you very much